yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes
happy Wednesday everybody
oh man make this weekend
no I'm sorry so it's just a measly 524
days till the 2024 election the same
amount of time it took Joe Biden to read
Charlotte's Web as a freshman in college
so welcome back into the spotlight Iowa
the birthplace of vending machines slice
bread and heterosexuals
on Tuesday Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
held his first campaign event in a tour
that will also take him to New Hampshire
and South Carolina but I wonder if it
was great to be back
it is great to be back and it's great
for me to report that our Great American
comeback starts by sending Joe Biden
back to his basement in Delaware
well the rest of the speech hit the
usual stuff but the left's Meltdown is
already in mid-season form when it comes
to Ron because there's a model for what
this little dictator in the making wants
to do
there is a model for what this little
dictator in the making wants to do just
look at China Cuba North Korea
Afghanistan or Iran where the government
censors the media or Force feeds a
strict conservative religious ideology
to children in schools deploys morality
police to make sure you're wearing what
they want learning what they want doing
what they want yeah
you gotta hand it to her she's just one
woman but possesses the stupidity of
five
she's like the view rolled into one
Super Burrito of lunacy
there's a quick fact check religion is
not encouraged in China the cultural
revolution was famous for destroying
temples and obviously it's not
Republicans pushing gender brainwashing
schools that forces kids to address
sexuality well before they know the
timetables hardly it's teacher slash
activists from Joy reads world who force
feed kids the do's and don'ts of
Washington dildo in the dishwasher ew I
know got to take out the batteries
so it makes you wonder if
it worked to sound so stupid she must
practice six hours a day because she's
got it down pat but you see the lock
step taking shape DeSantis is Public
Enemy Number One as is any Republican
who might win an election meanwhile the
first official Jabs between DeSantis and
Trump have already begun and Chris
Christie is planning to hop into the
race next week
[Applause]
right after he gets a clean bill of
health from his trainer at SeaWorld
something about his blowhole being
clogged with fluff a Nutter
would say
disgusting the things that they write
but you know some say he is presidential
and that he's already the candidate most
shaped like the Oval Office
another Fat folk would say terrible
people
but it may be an uphill battle for him
and others since a recent poll finds
nearly two out of three GOP voters think
Trump would be the strongest candidate
to beat Biden
speaking of polls Trump wasn't too happy
with his former press secretary Kaylee
mcanady on Tuesday he accused her of
inflating desantis's numbers during an
appearance on something called the Jerry
Waters show
writing quote Kaylee milk toast mcanini
just gave out the wrong poll numbers I'm
34 points up on D sanctimonious not 25
up while 25 is great it's not 34. the
rhinos and globalists can have her Fox
News should really only use real stars
I know real stars but I've been saying
that for years and they still won't hire
Chuck Woolery
of course that's Trump you love it or
hate it it is persuasive strategy you
can get angry about it but I doubt
Kaylee is so why should you Trump runs
on reciprocity you say something good
about him he returns the favor you don't
then he will return that too
it's fine but there is one flaw he gives
no break for time served she was his
best press secretary and those years
spent on the front lines for him should
count for something but it's his most
effective tool of persuasion so he can't
quit the question is can we by just
ignoring it and I think so because the
Dems they love it because it keeps us
busy beating up on each other
it's why I say Trump is a two-hour drive
to an hour at the beach the road is
Bumpy and exhausting especially when
allies receive friendly fire but
remember every Republican will have a
rough ride because no matter who that
person is there will be accusations of
bigotry sexism homophobia for the media
every Republican is just another
Apocalypse in khakis
so while Trump might be two hours to the
beach DeSantis might be 90 minutes but
what if the beach is it is nice
then I blame women white women white
women in particular about time right
Sonny
I I think that women white women in
particular want to protect this
patriarchy here because it's to their
benefit they want to make sure that
their husbands do well they want to make
sure that their sons do well they want
to make sure that their children do well
and they want to make sure that they do
well most of the women and some of these
studies are married white women and they
do fall in line with what their husbands
are doing what their husbands
take that people who say she's racist
you forget that she's also sexist
maybe it hasn't occurred to her that
people with similar opinions get married
sometimes
but maybe she got that opinion about
white ladies getting their opinions from
their husbands
from her husband
which is why she hasn't called him a
bigot right the bottom line she managed
to take a general observation that
spouses of any stripe stick together and
make it only about whites and why
because what else does she have nothing
she's not funny or smart or interesting
but she's an expert in calling people
racist so congrats on that and so as
each new Republican enters The Fray the
latest will be crowned no doubt worse
than Hitler meanwhile Joe retreats to
his basement living on bologna
sandwiches with the crust cut off
dusting off bowling trophies and
sniffing Jill's old wigs
sorry Dr Jill thank you
right Joe
yeah
like Ron gone I don't care they're both
Maga
all right you know Mega it's a little
place population no thank you
but I can think on both of these guys
I'll just do what I did last time I'll
go in the basement and then I let other
people figure it out with the votes and
all that kind of thing
but uh then we can make America great
again no wait a minute that's your thing
that's Maga I'm uh what do I do I'm
gonna do
whatever I
do do it
let's welcome tonight's guest
she talked so fast her tongue has to
wear a helmet oh so the new Fox Nation
series weapons of war
Emily cabano
his IQ is over 120 and his spf's over
250. Fox news's widest contributor Tom's
Lou
[Applause]
you could use her left leg to pick a
lock Foxy's contributor captive
[Applause]
and finally when God said let there be
light he asked him to step aside my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion
Tom
join me in at some speculation here yeah
I think the Dems want to go up against
Trump
and that's why they're laying off him
yes that's what I was saying obviously
the the media they're they're they're
all against DeSantis and they're
starting to praise Trump Lincoln project
was just praising Trump and attacking
descent yes oh by God Lincoln project
said he was more alpha or who's that
jerk who's the uh you know yeah I know
Rick Wilson yeah they they do fear
DeSantis I do think they want to run
against Trump but I think there's
another reason DeSantis is the most
popular governor in America and he's
quite Maga Trump changed the country and
they don't want to admit that he did the
the left and the Lincoln project the old
school Republicans they don't want to
admit that that old Republican party is
gone right the voters have moved Beyond
it that's why they like DeSantis he's
about the most Maga guy there is besides
Trump that's why those two guys are at
the top of the game but even the never
trumpers who are pure Hypocrites will
not do DeSantis either right right but
you know why I think because they fear
him even more than Trump because he's
the continuation of Maga we to continue
the Maga movement in this country and
the voters know it they're never going
back to that old Republican but they
think if they can maybe run against
Trump and defeat him again then they can
put the whole thing behind them but
DeSantis is the future and everybody
knows that ugh another great perspective
from a white male
see Trump like bash people that have
worked really hard for him but then I
think that that's just a part of his
persuasive mechanism which is like if
you do something nice I I give you a
treat if you don't and it's actually
just it's like she didn't do anything
really bad what's your take on this
Kaylee deserves only and the utmost
respect and kindness and generosity from
her current colleagues and from any
former colleagues and any former
employees
um I want to talk for a bit about Sunny
Hosten because her absolute ignorant
dribble the fact that it didn't spark
any outrage to me is what's most
appalling do you realize if anyone other
than her if anyone had bashed any other
group other than white women there would
have been an uproar an outrage we heard
across the globe where are the feminists
where are the feminists that are rising
up and saying oh if you are not a
married woman then you do have value
she's essentially saying in this cloak
of I'm committed to diversity inclusion
and Equity that one particular group
does even hold any value and can't think
for themselves and to me that just
illustrates how that party if you dare
think for yourself that's exactly why
you're shunned what would she say to
Hillary Clinton
right to anyone
but anyone that's a Democrat that is
that's married that's white
um and the fact that it was dead silence
that it was crickets from anyone on the
misogyny on the sexism on the absolute
hypocritical nature of everything out of
her mouth to me that's the worst part
because Casey DeSantis remember had an
absolute hit piece out on her by
Politico they said stay in your lane
rumor has it that she's getting too
involved in her husband's political
Affairs so which is it if it stay in
your lane or is it think for yourself
they can't get it together with women
drivers
[Laughter]
you know what I'm saying
sexist yeah I tricked you all right cat
do you uh feel do you agree that uh that
your husband Cameron has influenced your
voting habits or influence some of my
habits yes like I don't eat food in bed
anymore
unless I put a towel down and ask
permission I agreed to stop using his
blow dryer as a personal heater because
he has a nice one Italian yeah
um I have agreed to keep Cutlery in the
house oh that's good right well rather
than just using the plastic stuff that
they get with your order yeah um in
terms of voting no he hasn't
I still vote the same and I don't think
she even understood the point she was
making she's like these women they want
their husbands to be happy and they want
their kids to be happy and they want to
be happy as opposed to black women like
yeah I think everybody wants that but I
I just don't see I would like her to
explain to me how it is a you know fight
against the patriarchy to have voted for
an old man who has been in our
government 20 of the time we've been a
country yeah how is that that forward
thinking and Progressive I would like to
have that be explained to me rather than
just how maybe the other people are bad
now how is this person how does that
make you this forward-thinking
Progressive person because for me
um I I I don't want to live under a
patriarchy and for me that starts with
not you know wanting to call the
government daddy like a lot of these big
government jerks do there you go that's
so true thank you progressives actually
are pro patriarchy because they want a
government that takes care of you like a
big sugar daddy
all right Tyrus last word to you I I
just found to to
hop on cat's Point
um
the the idea that women listen to their
husband is just shocking
pulled a group of husband buddy of mines
and I asked if any of you have seen this
I even went specifically to the white
ones and they they said they had to
check with their wives before they
answered me so
[Applause]
yeah I don't I don't think that's how it
works I mean that sounds awesome
you know where's my food yeah vote for
Trump
where's my food there's it doesn't
happen not in this day in age but you're
right she's a complete she you
want your sons to do well you want your
kids to do well you want your daughters
to do well uh you you want everyone to
do well uh because that's how racists
roll yeah
with Bayard going yeah yeah yeah okay
no one watches the view they just turn
it on when they're trying to pretend to
be sick from going to work right so
put it on something else try static yeah
you know or like the sounds of cows
mating would probably be even better
just because at least that you know what
they're doing I read a study uh when uh
like when they do these social house
calls like people go and check on people
what do they call the Social House
checks yeah and they find dead people
it's always they're always watching The
View
it counts for at least uh half of their
viewers or actually Corpses
yeah I'll get you the citation for that
racist corpses racist corpses they used
to be white but they want the corpses to
do well they want the corpse families to
do well they want the skeletons in their
closets to do well
just go with moo all right before we go
tickets are available for my upcoming
book tour that's exciting I'll be in
Atlanta Clearwater Fort Myers Providence
and Reading Pennsylvania that's going to
be fun go to gutfeld.com for details hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else